[Music]
in desparate high news ooh like they're
desperate to get high yeah submitted by
who tried this first is it jenkum I
think wait wait but can I guess so
someone huffed something and got brain
damage and their vegetable now oh the
slug thing was that the slug is it the
Sun no okay alright we're up to date
police have arrested several teenagers
for getting intoxicated on a very bar
bizarre and disgusting concoction this
what state that's what you said I'm not
gonna light up their [ __ ] and they were
Mellish and then they get high with that
no this one I think and worse is that
some prisons is it an animal is it come
it's not an animal it's not come I know
what this is oh is it a dead body no
open I think that alternative ways to
get high no look more destroying more
organic material EPP okay no period
blood house sanitary pad like used
sanitarium oh these teens are going into
the trash
digging oh yeah so you're saying I can
sell drugs right now yep your drug
smuggler should get someone high so they
boil them and they extract certain
chemicals and then they drink this water
what's hotter than to experience
hallucinations
what how about [ __ ] that they figure
this chlorine or something right there's
chlorine or something well they just go
for the chlorine I know
moving in went Oh sodium polyacrylate
oh I saw something in the article
because I saw this one too and I thought
it said something about chlorine is in
either I don't know what fits the bodily
fluids or if it's like in the glue of
the path and this okay did you say these
are high schoolers chlorine on this one
hmm
you said this was her yeah mom with this
is Indonesia okay teeny okay well I
don't know maybe Seiko I don't know
what's going on but if kids were doing
weird stuff to get high they were
probably a little like more cool like
rebellious and like Chu who the [ __ ] is
sniffing Tampa right that's like the
opposite got drinking drinking drinking
the water boiled tampon tampon tee pad
imagine trying to sound cool man I got
so high off the pad last night whose is
that he says that like he shows enough
parties I was so good right now
ah [ __ ] man would you take period always
brand
yikes I don't even know what a maxi he's
got like 8 ounces of have your maxi
Bueller so I should have been if I
could've been making money sell like 10
years old right mm-hmm you started with
you that's ugh really
yeah I'm trying to think how much would
you have made by now 13 when I'm on a
ten you're 15 oh wow yeah that's crazy
how about you guys we're 14 Wow what the
[ __ ] happened to me what about you
remember I mean like 12 probably like 12
13 nothing it was like a lord like in
middle school mm-hmm my it came before I
even got boobs I was like let me get
like a little titty [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna
get before I was it comes to get boys by
saying you know I'm on my period I need
some titty to go with this you know and
you know the boobs come after to be
hormones
did your mama's her boobs do your mom I
had boobs and yours too yeah okay mine
where my mom's were faked so I was
waiting I was waiting and never happened
that's why these [ __ ] real boobs and
nothing happened I'm like yeah say my
mom has like at least it almost a c-cup
and I'm still over here in the alien my
mom's a D and I was a deeper brief
period in highschool boobs because I got
gained a lot of weight and and then damn
you got it - Adi mm-hmm and it was like
a hole deep but I was yeah about he's so
I'm a size 2 now and normally like even
being like 10 pounds overweight or
whatever um but in high school I was a
size 14 Oh
14 it's a lot of difference on my frame
with age or did you actually put effort
until you yeah no well okay so first I
didn't know anything about calories or
anything I just always ate intuitively
and then you know when you run through
puberty you're just like so hungry and
like so I just kept eating and I didn't
know that you could gain weight I really
didn't know about all that stuff until I
gained a bunch of weight and that all my
friends were all into like you know
binging and purging basically oh wow
yeah and so I couldn't do that but then
I yeah I got into this like obsessive
exercise thing but then it got really
like it was kind of unhealthy and yeah
and then I didn't develop a good
relationship with food until I was like
20 and then every year after 20 I was
losing weight until like 26 and then
then that like I think age caught up
yeah but it was yeah it was really it
was interesting I was always like
thinner as a kid but then in high school
I just like blew up oh you didn't see
the picture that David was making fun of
me for idea I was looking at your face
girl oh [ __ ] to me oh yeah well I guess
it didn't really zoom in on this area
but yeah like yeah Wow yeah no wonder
you have such a great personality
bullied in school
hell yeah okay I got bullied about being
pigeon-toed though you're gonna tono
bowlegged and I was like is this all
your guy you were both legged with I
guess cuz my legs are just like inverted
and I'm microstamping and I'm a child
[Laughter]
yeah my feet went in and it was like um
so like when I walked like a natural
like it was like this and y'all have a
big butt anyway yeah and so like it was
like this and I just give you walk in
that way it's good it's for the viewers
yeah
when I'm drunken when I'm tired it still
comes out but yeah then the kids were
making fun of the way I walked and stuff
and they wouldn't be friends with me
because I was like a dork and then my
mom put me in ballet and then yeah it's
a huge sob story whatever but after did
that I think I just realized that I was
bowlegged and pigeon processed now I'm
gonna change my walk like I like and it
was fine but like like I just that just
brought back memories like I think I was
seriously I didn't have any
self-awareness at all like I was just
ain't my life as a kid mm Wow a lot of
girls are so mean
our vision child on purpose yeah now and
pisses me off on purpose cause it's cute
yeah it's cute I'm like why couldn't
have been cute when I was a kid in it
mmm I'm operating yep they're
appropriating yeah so back to these
period drinkers oh so they're saying
that drinking this water in large
quantities could damage organs like
kidneys and liver and even cause cancer
well yeah what about the toxic shuck
stuff is that in pads too or is it just
in tampons I think it's I tell your body
reacts to it I don't think I think the
toxicity huh cotton wasn't it no I think
it's no it's something that has to do
with how your body reacts to the being
bacteria this type of thing and I mean
once you take it out I don't think
there's like toxic shock something in it
oh I thought it was in the cotton or
something I don't know anything about it
I don't know that much I just got scared
and yeah tampons like I never leave
especially when they named it something
horrifying like toxic shock syndrome
yeah the video about a girl that lost
her leg from it oh my god like she was
like yeah yeah I've been using tables on
my life it was just a normal day I
didn't use it longer than I normally do
it she's I always thought it was that
like 14 hour thing that's when it it's
gonna yeah like when you go to sleep for
like a 24 hour I think they said that
you have to have it in for like certain
30-day toriel infection that's what it
is I read there was a girl in my old
city that like had a tampon in there and
forgot and she put another one in there
oh yeah
but that the old one just stayed in
their home while she died from it
oh my gosh yeah toxic all the toxic
sucks that's crazy and that's all
well it's saying here that toxic shock
syndrome can affect anyone including men
and children post-metal women risk
factors include skin wounds and surgery
it's just a bacterium oh I thought it
was a tampon exclusive yeah me too
I've heard of it used in other in other
cases but I'm not sure how disrespect
Tyrael cuz like the organic tampons
their whole thing is like we don't
bleach our tampon so like yeah I thought
there was like less of a chance of you
getting it or something like that
I'm just really curious as to how these
guys figured it out cuz sniffing tampons
- [ __ ] it's one thing but like hey let's
boil it and then maybe extract the
certain chemical like you're kind of
dumb but smart at the same time in a way
yeah what they're doing is that they're
getting this like certain chemical that
is used to absorb the liquids and that's
what they're extracting from so not the
blood necessarily it's just that they're
getting the the pads from the trashcan
just by the pan but having school nurses
and ships they don't have money out
there trying to get high yeah had the
money they'd probably by some other
think that boiling blood is like it's a
good hygienic yeah crows oh my god so
yeah this one's real bad disappointed
yeah as everyone I clicked on this video
I must prevent some fruit or something
yeah like a gel wine yeah a little bit
JW [ __ ] in a bucket do something that's
like yes understand oh the Indonesian
police have arrested several teenagers
oh my god
wonder if your guys are girls their age
between 13 and 16 and they came from
poor neighborhoods that can't afford
drugs
um just goes to show you the links
people go to just get [ __ ]
yeah that is why I mean some of the best
engineers ever are pot heads yeah yeah
if they don't have something to smoke oh
no he built rockets he's literally over
good scientists and he's high all the
time but like in like if they have
nothing to smoke out of they'll find
something to make it yeah oh yeah we did
that in high school for sure coke cans
apples anything yeah you know I think so
when I was in high school like the
dumbest thing that I ever used to get
high so it was two things so one was you
know it wasn't even like a high high is
just that I like the way it made me feel
which was like the choking game did you
guys ever hear that oh god the one that
kills kids every night girl everyday
Dupin is looking over it don't ever do
it
but yeah it's like you're just pretty
much making yourself pass out and I just
liked the woozy feeling that I regret
and so I would do that that's why I'm so
slow now in the other yeah that explains
a lot
and also this other thing so I would
also like inhale so dumb so embarrassed
no it's close to that it was air
freshener made like they redesign their
fish mercy you can't do it anymore but
back then they would be different where
you put like a towel over and like
inhale the fumes and then it would get
me so [ __ ] up me and my friend would
be so stupid and doing what kind of air
freshener was it um catch me your wick
like those like the restroom air
freshener as well do y'all remember
those uh those air fresheners that were
like India it had like a Native American
like an Indian on it kinda wait you look
at the little the little just like
Carter we're one and it was like [ __ ]
like the long thing never mind this
that's my home you do remember that I
missed that scent for the logo but I
feel like I was I've just lost so any
[ __ ] breathe yeah I think so my gosh
[Music]